parlons d'europe avec la maison de
l'europe des yvelines
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans parlons d'europe une émission
spéciale consacrée aux 20 ans de la
maison de l'europe des yvelines vous en
avez sûrement une à côté de chez vous il
y en a une trentaine en france mais de
quoi s'agit-il comment sont-elles nées
et à quoi sert veut-elle je suis avec
corentin alonso bonjour matisse il y en
a une trentaine partout en france à
saint germain en laye paris besançon
nice evreux nantes ou encore perpignan
ce sont des associations reconnues
d'utilité publique alors leur but faire
vivre l'europe sur tout le territoire
animer la réflexion sur l'europe et
réduire le fossé existant entre les
institutions européennes et les citoyens
elles sont nées à la fin des années 40
pour promouvoir les liens entre les
différents peuples européens aujourd'hui
elles sont le relais des institutions
sur le territoire l'union européenne
c'est un objet politique complexe on le
sait les maisons de l'europe sont là
pour vous aider justement à l'analyse et
à la comprendre mais aussi à pouvoir
vous faire votre propre avis dessus elle
organise des débats des soirées pour
échanger sur ces thèmes alors pour
résumer concrètement les maisons de
l'europe font un travail d'éducation
populaire à la citoyenneté européenne
elle participe également à des projets
avec d'autres maisons de l'europe
partout dans l'union situés dans
d'autres d'autres pays alors je crois qu
en tant qu il ya aussi des centres
d'information europe direct alors oui la
moitié des maisons de l'europe sont
labellisés centre d'information europe
direct
c'est un label décerné par la commission
européenne
ils font office de relais entre les
institutions européennes et l'échelon
local en informant sur les décisions
politiques qui ont été prises au niveau
européen
alors en tant que citoyen européen vous
avez probablement des questions et des
préoccupations concernant l'union
européenne ces centres accueillent tous
ceux qui se posent des questions
le fonctionnement de l'union sur les
actions ainsi que sur les financements
notamment ses centres il offre un
service d'information gratuits et sont à
même de donner des conseils et de
répondre à des questions sur tout ce qui
concerne l'union européenne c'est là-bas
que par exemple vous pouvez trouver
votre information sur votre prochain
voyage erasmus par exemple des
interventions pédagogiques dans les
collèges également et les lycées sont
organisées afin de sensibiliser les plus
jeunes à la citoyenneté européenne merci
beaucoup corentin pour ces précisions
parlons d'europe
et reguena le coin de vient de me
rejoindre bonjour regin a alors vous
êtes la secrétaire général de la maison
de l'europe des yvelines et surtout sa
fondatrice il ya 20 ans quelle est
l'histoire de la maison de l'europe à
bâle histoire c'est que on s'était dit
avec un certain nombre d'amis que
l'europe était convoyé les discussions
sur ceci celà c'est c'était certes pour
des spécialistes mais le citoyen lambda
son entrée c'est pas du tout il se
posait la question revient à l'europe
c'est n'importe quoi et c'est quoi en
dehors des technocrates qui parle donc
si cela on a dit mais il faudra
peut-être faire un lien entre les
institutions et les citoyens et
expliquer pourquoi l'europe c'est
vraiment quelque chose de super et de
surtout pour les citoyens et
donc il faut organiser des choses
surtout pour les jeunes soit on commence
le plus
comment ces jeunes mieux c'est donc et
c'est comme ça qu'on a commencé avec la
maison de l'europe à cette nécessité de
parler aux citoyens leur expliquer à
quoi sert l'union européenne
leurs 20 ans ce n'est pas rien comment
s'est passé l'évolution de la maison de
l'europe pendant ces vingt années où
c'était encore moi c'est tout petit on
est à 1 4 les signataires de
la convention et
on commence et surtout commencer à avec
les établissements scolaires ils ont
très vite fait appel à nous et on a
rené ans avenue que ce soit pour la
journée de l'europe que ça
ce soir est expliqué nous l'europe ça
dépend des après quel niveau on
n'intervenait et on a commencé à ce
concept libye mais qu'elle fait l'europe
est à avons nous ce qu'on a plein de
fait une saison plus de commémoration
des derniers a guère que des fêtes pour
une europe quand même donc gilles il
faudrait peut-être faire quelque chose
autour de la journée de l'europe et
c'est là qu'on a commencé c'était un dur
presque dix ans la semaine de l'europe
ou inviter nos partenaires
parfois on avait 90 jeunes et adultes de
deux mois sept à neuf pays européens
et c'était le sport c'est la culture
c'était la danse et le théâtre
c'est c'était le sport tennis foot donc
ça c'était très sympathique on a
toujours terminé avec une grande fête où
les sportifs étaient primés et les yeux
n'en montrer ce qu'ils ont fait en danse
en musique
donc il l'europe quelque part ces
supports pour nous d'abord cette
rencontre de l'autre essayait de
comprendre l'autre et de faire des
choses ensemble et là sport et musique
et danse c'était l'idéal pour faire des
choses ensemble sans nécessairement
parler les langues et bah merci beaucoup
ruinés devoir être avec nous
parlons d'europe
sénatrice mais aussi présidente de la
maison de l'europe des civils on
retrouve tout de suite martha de sidrac
avec nicolas kirilow means martha dos
idrac expliquez-nous un peu votre vision
à vous de l'europe quelle quelle image
vous avez l'europe oblige et politiques
souvent souvent critiqué par beaucoup
est ce que vous faites aussi partie de
ces gens qui disent que l'europe l'union
européenne notamment ne marche pas très
bien alors je crois tout d'abord
l'europe est très peu enfin l'union
européenne est très peu connu et je
crois que là-dessus nous avons tous un
grand devoir de pédagogie que l'on doit
faire vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
puisque c'est l'objet aussi d'ailleurs
de la réunion de nos 20 ans de ce soir
ça sera l'occasion de rappeler ce que
sont les institutions européennes qu'on
le leur que l'on connaît très mal en
réalité est également tout ce que
l'europe peut offrir aux citoyens
européens très largement français
évidemment moi en tant que français je
ne vais pas vous dire le contraire donc
je crois que le vrai sujet c'est la
méconnaissance que l'on a c'est une
grosse machine c'est une machine avec
des moyens c'est une machine avec des
envies c'est une machine avec des
visions et tout cela doit être amplement
partagée sur l'ensemble des territoires
des états membres et la complexité vient
essentiellement de là et c'est un combat
pour vous puisque vous êtes présidente
de cette maison de l'europe des yvelines
depuis depuis maintenant qu'est-ce qu'un
en quelques mois le comment comment vous
pouvez selon vous dans les yvelines par
exemple localement comment peuvent
améliorer justement ce rapport entre
cette grosse machine dont vous parliez
qu'est l'union européenne et les
yvelinois parce que on le sait enfin
très peu le savent mais pourtant il ya
beaucoup de fonds européen qui permette
d'investir dans des projets il ya
beaucoup de choses qui se font
localement comment on fait pour
justement rapprocher et faire comprendre
aux citoyens que le sujet européen est
très important il faut s'y intéresser
oui alors je pense qu'il faut que nous
améliorons notre communication ça c'est
en axes un axe fort que je souhaiterais
que l'on développe au sein de la maison
de l'europe des yvelines quand je dis
communication pour dire tout ce que nous
faisons tout ce que nous faisons
justement vis-à-vis de cette population
élargie et vis-à-vis de la jeunesse nous
sommes quand même dans l'année de là
jeunesse il est important de le rappeler
est l'événement de ce soir sera un de
ses outils de communication très large
puisque nous avons invité beaucoup de
nos élus de nos territoires que nous
souhaitons sensibiliser également à la
chose européenne et pour permettre à ce
que chacun y puisent l'intérêt qui
pourra être trouvé dans cette union
européenne qui pour moi est quand même
importante et nous sommes ici à saint
germain on l'est particulièrement un
territoire profondément européen
profondément internationale donc je
crois que nous sommes quand même pas si
mal placé que cela pour pouvoir porter
ce message vis-à-vis de nos concitoyens
comment comment vous observez ce sera ma
dernière question sans parler de pure
politique mais comment vous observez les
débats la façon dont se déroule cette
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne qui permet aussi de
mettre les projecteurs sur sur le sujet
de l'europe est ce que vous vous vous
trouvez qu'on en fait assez en france à
ce propos dans les médias elle avait des
plus jeunes comme vous en parliez
disons qu'on ne s'en sert pas toujours à
bon escient pour vous dire le fond de ma
pensée moi j'ai un petit regret sur
cette présidence française c'est en
terme de calendrier ça ne vous a pas
échappé nous sommes en période
électorale et nous seront amputées
mécaniquement c'est comme ça de quelques
mois de quelques semaines pour pouvoir
véritablement contribuer à cette
réflexion qui doit se mener au sein de
l'union européenne
donc ça c'est pour moi un profond regret
je voulais j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de
l'exprimer ce matin vous voyez on a
aussi moins au sénat j'avais initié un
colloque avec la première ministre de
serbie grands pays des balkans qui a
vocation d'intégrer l'union européenne
vous avez vu que le président de la
république a dit que les balkans
occidentaux était l'une des priorités de
cette présidence française tout cela
reste quand même relativement encore
méconnue et souvent objet de clivage qui
ne devrait pas être là de mon point de
vue et je pense que là dessus nous avons
tous collectivement une responsabilité à
la fois pour faire connaître l'europe
voilà vous savez j'ai une phrase toute
bête que je répète à qui veut l'entendre
quand on ne connaît pas on ne peut pas
aimer donc l'europe il faut commencer
par la connaître et c'est en ça que je
vais moi même investir beaucoup
amplement avec toute l'équipe de la
maison de l'europe des yvelines vous les
connaissez ce sont des personnes très
motivées et je compte beaucoup sur eux
pour que au moins dans les yvelines
qu'on connaisse mieux laurent et pour
les peut-être encore vingt prochaines
années merci ah bah j'espère plus que ça
encore plus que ça aux commerçants de
convaincre merci à vous parle ou
d'europe
pierrefonds maire de sartrouville et
président de l'union des maires des
yvelines est interrogé par nicolas
kirillovitch sur le lien entre des
petites communes et l'europe pierrefonds
en qualité de président de l'union des
maires des yvelines est ce que pouvait
un peu nous expliquer comment vous vous
agissez concrètement peut-être au
quotidien aussi avec vos autres mandats
pour créer du lien entre des petites
communes parfois évinoise et puis cette
grosse entité cette grosse machine
qu'est l'union européenne qui a aussi
peut-être davantage pour vous d'avoir
des fonds européens qui peuvent aider
les petites communes comment comment
créer ce lien entre d et petites
structures il est beaucoup plus grosse
d'abord mon jeu il ya d'abord à titre
personnel un lien sentimental avec
l'europe parce que je suis né en
lorraine et autour de nombreux chiner
avec des champs de bataille de toutes
les guerres franco allemande est chez
moi dans ma famille on a toujours été
profondément européen est ce que
l'europe c'est la paix et donc on a en
visualiser ce que l'absence d'europe
avait amené nos cours de l'histoire et
les drames que ça apporte bien sûr pour
les communes l'europe est parfois très
loin surtout en ile de france parce que
en ile de france on passe par la région
par l'état par les départements et donc
on a une vision peu lointaine mais il
nous appartient aussi de construire des
projets qui peuvent recevoir un soutien
européen je pense aux particuliers à
deux types de projets les projets
économiques bien sûr et les projets
aussi qui touche la mutation d'un
certain nombre de quartiers puisque
l'union européenne intervient aussi pour
transformer nos territoires qu'est ce
que vous disent parfois peut-être volé
les maires que vous rencontrez des
petites communes à propos du sujet
européen on sait que c'est un sujet très
clivant au sein de la de la société il
ya ceux qui sont en projet européen
notamment peut-être les plus jeunes et
puis ceux qui critiquent beaucoup
l'europe sur sa complexité son inutilité
la souveraineté qu'elle nous prendrait
aussi sa difficulté à monter des
dossiers tout simplement pour des
petites pour des petites communes qu
est-ce qu est-ce qui vous disent vous
les acteurs locaux de c2c territoire
qu'est ce qui est le message qui vous
font passer à propos de l'europe je
pense que il ya un double message
d'abord et un message un peu de
complexité
et c'est vrai qu'à monter les dossiers
par équité des dossiers à les connaître
même à savoir qu'il y a alors c'est pas
propre à l'europe savez la complexité
elle existe aussi au niveau français au
niveau régional au niveau départemental
c'est comme ça monte des dossiers de
demande de subventions c'est difficile
c'est complexe et plus la commune est
petit plus ses moyens sont limités et
donc vous avez une difficulté est là
dessus et puis c'est aussi je pense que
c'est propre à la france est aussi
beaucoup d'ignorance sur ce qui se fait
à l'europe voyez c'est une sorte de
distance chi chi chi vinh nourrit des
fantasmes qui nourrit le fait de deux
peut-être une incompréhension et je
pense qu'on a travaillé la maison de
l'europe et ça aussi on a travaillé sur
une meilleure connaissance de ce qu'est
l'europe alors paradoxalement on le sait
tous parce que nous sommes tous jumelée
avec des communes européennes oui et
cette pratique du jumelage est très
ancienne alors ça passe pas par l'europe
en tant qu'institution mais ma ville par
exemple est jumelée avec une ville
grecque une ville portugaise d'une ville
allemande et ces échanges qui nourrit
des villes et des voyages parfois ou des
échanges entre des voyages et puis en
même temps des échanges sur des projets
et puis en même temps plaisir d'être
ensemble c'est ça aussi l'europe et le
fait qu'on remarque tout cette grande
proximité en termes de civilisation qui
nous unit donc on ne puissiez pas des
territoires très lointain donc il ya des
choses communes voilà maintenant il ya à
surmonter l'idée de complexité et les
intercoms ça peut être
pour ça la région aussi pour pouvoir
monter des dossiers dead de financement
sur des sujets d assainissement
d'aménagement du territoire de
développement économique pas voilà tous
ces sujets là et aussi peut-être des
rencontres organisés des débats au sein
des collectivités auprès des plus jeunes
aussi comment on peut favoriser le lien
entre l'union européenne et c'est cette
jeunesse l'intéressé on sait ça peut
être compliqué de l'intéressé à la
politique parfois alors au sujet de
l'union européenne peut-être encore plus
comment on peut on peut essayer de
réussir cela ben moi je crois que c'est
aussi au niveau du déroulement des
études il ya dans beaucoup de communes
maintenant des services ou des bureaux
qui sont montés d'orientation et
d'information dans le post bac de plus
en plus il y à des cursus à l'étranger
et ses cursus peuvent être européen et à
tous les dispositifs des deux stages de
formations européennes et énormément de
jeunes quelles que soient leurs
formations sont très friands de parce
qu'ils savent bien que leur vie
professionnelle et même leur vie
culturelle va se dérouler dans ce cadre
européen et hélas il ya aussi à faire
connaître ces dispositifs qui permettent
un jeune de notre territoire bah après
le bac de continuer dans une école
université française avec des partis qui
vont se dérouler l'étranger notamment
dans l'ordre merci beaucoup pierrefonds
merci beaucoup parlons d'europe avec la
maison de l'europe des yvelines sur
sensations avec le soutien financier de
l'union européenne
une émission qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe et de la grande consultation
citoyenne qui est actuellement en cours
vous êtes d'ailleurs invité à donner
votre avis et partager vos idées sur la
plateforme numérique futur e u point
europa.eu thème de ce numéro les
institutions européennes on a parfois du
mal à s'y retrouver comme a pu le
constater maiolo bain qui est allé vous
posez la question je sais qu'il ya le
parlement et à la commission européenne
et qui a le conseil des ministres
européens
non franchement à strasbourg
et à bruxelles oui voilà
le parlement européen non non non trois
malades vous pourriez pas m'en citer
non il ya la commission
qui malheureusement n'est pas élu donc
c'est pas très démocratique
il ya une présidente de la commission
et puis il ya la roja baisse à
l'assemblée mais c'est là
j'ai pas comme on dit enfin la réunion
de tous les faits les députés européens
qui ont le parlement ah voilà
le parlement européen bien sûr c'est
vrai qu'en fait c'est super difficile
encore comme question parlement européen
espère puis c'est tout quoi non non non
plus qu'on sait qu'on sait de doha
parlement européen
la présidence présidence européenne est
ce que vous connaissez au moins leur
rôle par exemple non très mal à fédérer
les tous les pays et trouver des
solutions ensemble talent la commission
européenne qui est à bruxelles c'est
celle qu'on connaît le mieux c'est un
peu l'organe exécutif ben on a du mal à
comprendre à quoi sert pour beaucoup le
rôle et le fonctionnement des
institutions européennes est parfois
floue on vient de le voir mais pas
d'inquiétude notre journaliste nicolas
kirillovitch est avec nous pour nous
éclairer sur le sujet bonsoir nicolas
bonsoir matisse effectivement je vais
essayer de vous aider il ya cette
institution européenne la première
peut-être la plus importante
politiquement c'est le conseil européen
il réunit les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de l'union européenne
27 pays aujourd'hui depuis le départ de
de la grande-bretagne et de et le break
site le conseil européen le conseil
aussi on l'appelle parfois il fixe les
grandes orientations politiques de
l'union européenne aujourd'hui il est
présidé par l'ancien premier ministre
belge charles michel en résumé le
conseil européen celle ainsi c'est
l'instance suprême qui se concentre sur
les grandes orientations politiques et
générale de l'union européenne un peu
comme si vous aviez en réalité 27
emmanuel macron qui se réunissait pour
décider de l'impulsion à donner aux
politiques européennes et qui tranche
aussi en cas de blocage persistantes
entre les institutions à côté de ce
conseil européen il y à la commission
européenne elle est la gardienne des
traités de l'union européenne elle
défend les intérêts de l'union
européenne parfois au conseil européen
ce sont un peu les égoïsmes nationaux
qui joue là avec la commission
européenne ce sont vraiment les intérêts
de l'union européenne qui sont défendues
la commission européenne est la seule à
être doté de l'initiative législative
dans le domaine des compétences de l'ue
eux contrairement à la france par
exemple où les parlementaires peuvent
faire des propositions de loi là c'est
seulement la compétence de la commission
open aujourd'hui présidée par
l'allemande ours ou la vendline et il y
à 27 membres qui 27 membres de cette
commission européenne un pour chacun des
pays aux gros pays elle les grosses
commissions généralement ça marche ainsi
le front c'est thierry breton est en
charge du marché intérieur c'est lui qui
était responsable des législations sur
le numérique qui doivent permettre à
l'europe d'être un peu plus indépendant
sur le sujet vis-à-vis des géants du
numérique américains et chinois alors
vous vous en avez cité deux médias aussi
je prends le conseil de l'union
européenne nicolas tout à fait le
conseil de l'union européenne à ne pas à
ne pas confondre avec le conseil
européen dont j'ai parlé au début le
conseil de l'union européenne lui il
réunit les ministres de chacun des états
membres pour voter les lois proposées
par la commission européenne et j'espère
que vous suivez pour l'instant ma
difficile c'est un peu compliqué donc le
conseil de l'union européenne et co
législateur avec le parlement européen
le conseil de l'union européenne se
réunissent selon les compétences de
chacun des ministres s'il ya un sujet
des transports ça va être les 27
ministres des transports des pays
membres de l'ue eux qui vont se réunir
pour amender peut-être ou modifier les
propositions de loi de la commission
européenne et je vous le disais il fait
cela en parallèle avec le parlement
européen que l'on connaît un peu mieux
ils sont 705 c'est parlementaires
européens qui eux agissent donc en co
législateur avec le conseil de l'union
européenne on peut citer les autres
trois grands d'autres institutions de
l'union européenne il ya la cour de
justice de l'union européenne qui est
chargée d'examiner la légalité des actes
européen là c'est un peu plus complexe
mais il y à cette cour de justice de
l'union européenne il est aussi la
banque centrale européenne présidée par
christine lagarde qui elle est en charge
de gérer la monnaie unique des 19
membres de la zone euro et puis il ya la
cour des comptes européenne qui marche
comme la cour des comptes en france voir
si beaucoup ils veulent a perdu ou par
matisse je pense que l'on voit un peu
plus clair en tout cas merci beaucoup
pour ces précisions parlons d'europe
avec la maison de l'europe des yvelines
sur sensations avec le soutien financier
de l'union européenne
et on va revenir en france à présent
pour s'intéresser aux relations
entretenues par notre parlement et plus
particulièrement le sénat avec les
institutions européennes et nos voisins
européens
corentin alonso est avec le sénateur
jean françois rapin président de la
commission des affaires européennes vous
êtes sénateur du pas-de-calais vous êtes
le président de la commission des
affaires européennes du sénat il y en a
aussi
une autre commission des affaires
européennes à l'assemblée nationale
présidée par la députée sabine tilaï
quel est le rôle de ces deux commissions
ya d'abord ces deux commissions elles
sont définies et elles existent parce
que la constitution de la décider donc
elles ont aujourd'hui un rôle à la fois
d'information auprès des différentes
chambres dans lesquelles elles sont
aussi bien le sénat que l'assemblée
nationale auprès des collègues sur
l'actualité sur l'information européenne
et notamment sur les textes qui sortent
elle a aussi un rôle de contrôle alain
rôle de contrôle des textes au travers
ce qu'on appelle la subsidiarité la
proportionnalité puisque l elle précise
finalement aussi les textes européens
sont
tout à fait conformes au plan de la
subsidiarité et de la proportionnalité
avec ce qu'attendent les états les états
membres et comment ils les reçoivent ça
c'est le premier point puis on a aussi
un rôle et de
d'interpellation auprès de nos
gouvernements pour que le gouvernement
qui a son propre mandat et son propre
calendrier puisse aussi avoir de
l'information de la part d' des
parlements nationaux et entre autres
chez nous du sénat sous la forme et on
présente ça sous la forme de deux
résolutions de résolution qui
qui incite le gouvernement à porter le
message du parlement puis en dernier
lieu vis-à-vis directement des
institutions européennes nous pouvons
émettre des avis politique sur certains
textes sur certaines directives
sur certains règlements et nous ainsi
nous pouvons nous pouvons influer et le
sénat fait partie ces institutions qui
arrive à influer un petit peu sur les
institutions européennes au travers ses
différentes ces différents outils or
vous le savez nous avons pleine
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne qu'est ce que vous en
attendez à ce que c'est l'occasion de
parler plus d'europe au sénat mais aussi
dans la nature je ne sais pas si ce sera
l'occasion de parler plus d'europe en
tout cas c'est une charge de travail
complémentaire pour les deux chambres
parlementaires puisque nous animons bien
sûr des réunions qui sont propres
aux institutions telles qu'elles sont
établies entre autres je pense à la
cosaque qui est la conférence des
organes chargés justement que ces
affaires de ces affaires européennes et
donc nous sommes réunis sous deux
formats avec des membres de chaque
commission des parlements nationaux
qui travaillent sur les sujets sur les
sujets européens et donc nous la
présidence cette année puisque c'est
l'année de la présidence française donc
à la fois savent-ils et moi-même
coprésidents 7,7 kozak après il ya des
événements parlementaires qui sont qui
sont proposés alors bien sûr on a reçu
nous la cosac des présidents les
présidents des des chambres
parlementaires des vingt-sept sont venus
à paris et en visio et et nous essayons
eux dès lors de deux constituées de
réunir tout le monde mais sous
l'autorité de la france
voilà donc c'est une charge de travail
complémentaire administrative
diplomatique mais c'est aussi un beau
challenge est ce que les médias et les
politiques mais triste il suffisamment
les sujets européens c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile j'ai fait
j'ai fait récemment j'ai organisé
récemment au sénat une table ronde
justement pour eux à la fois échangé
avec les médias nationaux mais aussi les
médias européens sur la façon dont nos
patrouilles ont mieux les uns et les
autres communiquer c'est sûrement de
notre faute les sujets européens
paraissent très éloignés de nos citoyens
est forcément si c'était l'éloigner des
citoyens ça intéresse beaucoup moins la
presse néanmoins il ya des choses quand
même essentiel très importante
je rappelle que
l'europe a des conseillers des
compétences quasi exclusive sur le sur
l'agriculture sur la pêche
endroit transfrontalier on a des sujets
qui sont des sujets de migration
aujourd'hui et avec un avec un rôle très
important de plus en plus important qui
doit être jouée par l'europe donc tous
ces sujets doivent devrait intéresser
par est intéressé plus peut-être qu'on
en parle aussi nous on n'a pas su à un
certain moment
vulgariser le message européen
quand je dis vulgariser ce n'est pas
péjoratif c'est comment porter le
message européen à la portée de tous nos
concitoyens comment rapprocher l'europe
des citoyens comment faire ce concept
que je défends donc dans beaucoup de mes
allocution le compte le contexte
d'europe à la maison justement quelles
sont les pistes pour essayer d'améliorer
ce ce sujet puisque c'est quand même
qu'il ya quelque chose d'important pour
la démocratie
dans les deux sens c'est à dire que les
politiques doivent faire beaucoup de
pédagogie l'europe c'est de la politique
l'europe c'est de la diplomatie mais
l'europe c'est aussi de la pédagogie
c'est beaucoup de pédagogie de notre
part les élus et puis les médias ont
peut être aussi une réflexion sur la
façon dont ils doivent présenter les
sujets les sujets européens et les
rendre beaucoup plus à la fois plus
concret mais plus accessible merci
beaucoup je viens france à rabat on
arrive au terme de cette émission vous
le savez une grande consultation
citoyenne est actuellement en cours vous
êtes invités à vous exprimer et à
imaginer l'europe de demain je vous
rappelle d'ailleurs l'adresse de la
plateforme numérique future rue point
europa.eu plateforme a mis en place à
l'occasion de la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe vous pourrez ainsi partager
vos idées sur différents thèmes
changement climatique santé justice
sociale emploi démocratie européenne et
un tas d'autres choses parlons d'europe
c'est terminé on se retrouve très
bientôt merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous cette émission a été enregistrée en
marge du 20e anniversaire de la maison
de l'europe des yvelines on espère a pas
répondu aux principales questions que
vous vous posez et n'oubliez pas de
prolonger le débat sur nos réseaux
sociaux c'était parlons d'europe sur
sensations plus d'infos sur maison
europe 78e
[Musique]